c'est un combat de coq et le terrain de
jeu c'est l'espace cela fait des années
que les deux milliardaires se livrent
une bataille féroce pour la conquête
spatiale Elon Musk d'un côté patron de
Space X cherchant à devenir le
Christophe Colomb des temps modernes
prononçant des discours aux accents
messianiques
et puis Jeff Bezos face à lui patron
d'Amazon très marqué par les premiers
pas sur la Lune chatouillés par les
ambitions de musc et piqué au vif par
ses succès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais que ce soit pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons ces deux hommes ont
tout de même révolutionné l'industrie
spatiale très endormie depuis quelques
années ils ont ouvert la conquête de
l'espace au privé casser les prix
bousculer la NASA et l'Europe réveiller
les appétits de la Chine et de la Russie
alors question maintenant jusqu'où ira
la commercialisation de l'espace et à
quel prix musk Bezos la nouvelle guerre
des étoiles avoir ce samedi à 21h sur
Public Sénat et puis sur notre site
Internet et notre chaîne YouTube